Patrick H Goodell is a political
strategist consultant and Fox News
contributor mr. Cadell has served as
chief public opinion poster and senior
adviser for the campaign's of Democratic
presidential candidates George McGovern
and Jimmy Carter he also served as a
personal adviser for President Carter
from 1977 to 1981 he has advised over
150 political campaigns including those
of Gary Hart Walter Mondale Jerry Brown
Joe Biden Edward Kennedy Edmund muskie
and Mario Cuomo from 1981 to 1984 he was
a member and vice chair of the US
Military Academy at West Point by
presidential appointment he has
consulted on a number of major motion
pictures including Apocalypse Now red
Air Force One and the line of fire and
breakout he was also a writer producer
and consultant for the Emmy
award-winning NBC series The West Wing
please join me in welcoming mr. Patrick
Goodell
that was a nice introduction Thank You
other a couple things that were left out
of my resume you're looking at the only
man has ever been bald losing 49 states
twice along the way and I also when I
worked at coca-cola I was involved in
New Coke which is another story can make
a movie over could really make a movie
about that the fiction is just great I
am a refugee from politics and by the
way I have to take this off because this
isn't true I am NOT from Alexandria
Virginia I have nothing to do with
Washington I left there in 1987 and they
only let me back in when I have a visa
I appear on Fox News some of you know on
Sunday nights on the show called
political insiders with Doug shown and
John lebu da we have a what an audience
in last and last night I announced that
I was talking about corruption and
politics and I said that 1972 I was the
youngest person on Richard Nixon's
enemies list and I was sure this year I
was going to qualify as the oldest
person on Hillary Clinton's enemies list
so that's quite a quite a distinguished
life now I want to say this by the way
for those of you at dinner I kept
thinking my gosh look at this whole
roomful of deplorable
only adults were in there
and and you know the irredeemable zuv
unredeemable z' and and then i come here
with the students i just want to say it
seeing the students here i just want to
know that you were not left out watching
the news site in hillary clinton is
getting a lot of flack because of her
attempted appeals the millennials and
then a tape came out where she was
discussing young people during the
primary and she called them baristas and
kids who live in their basement of their
parents homes and their don't understand
how things work in the audience of her
supporters were going crazy she's oh no
I was sympathizing with them and I they
show you her depth touch with young
people she went to the universe New
Hampshire because they realized they
were not winning young people the way
they should a lot of them are voting for
Gary Johnson and and Jill Stein and and
they didn't particularly care for her
all that much and and so she had an
event at the University New Hampshire
and brought Bernie Sanders who can't
stop saying enough things I'm a boy talk
about a guy who took a powder but to be
accepted but so he's there and what
happens was the room and filled up with
his sports students waited two and a
half hours and almost none of them could
get in and then Hillary Clinton had the
audacity to say young people would
always have a place at the table with
her so you have to understand why this
like ended of course Donald Trump has
his own moments where he has been saying
things that are just amazing
but I want to talk about this and I'm
going to start by talking about your
college here
Hillsdale when I was on the phone I'm
talking with mad about that and he was
giving me some background one of the
arguments I'm going to make tonight is I
discussed what's happened to my party
the Democratic Party in the Republican
Party and the country in 1854 on the the
Whig party which had won it predicted in
a wig was still sitting in the White
House and in the Whig party was wiped
out in the 1854 election it was a party
trying to straddle north and south on
slavery and free territories and a new
party began to arose arise and started
rip on Wisconsin and had roots in
Michigan called the Republican Party
which was made up of a lot of people who
had been Free Soil people Whigs former
Whigs and North others and they formed a
new party and that party and here is the
important historical realization that
party in its first election it was
formed in February in a in the November
of that year the Republican Party and
their allies are collective set of
allies slaughtered the Democrats and
took the House of Representatives in one
election cycle they came within one
state the next two years later in the
presidential election with with John
Fremont who was kind of a wild weird of
but anyway and almost won in the
Democrats began and held out winning
Pennsylvania but within one cycle
American politics had been turned on its
head and one of the parties that had
been the main stage disappeared and a
new party would have what it would end
up having dominance for some years and
that was one of the great major changes
along with that of the civil war and
their three identifiable major changes
in our political history of upheavals
after the depression in 1932 the
emergence of the
of the Democratic Party under Roosevelt
as a dominant party in the country after
having been the minority proud party and
his professor hammy said this today I
mean they had won almost nothing in the
1880s except in 90s except Grover
Cleveland's too interrupted terms and
Wilson's term and then we went back to
normalcy for several elections until the
stock market fell apart in the country
when a deep depression but the other one
was in 1824 and 1828 in 1820 point in
1824 the parties nominated their
presidents in caucuses in the House and
Senate the House of Representatives
really and they would nominate the
candidates that were going to run in the
parties and a gentleman named Andrew
Jackson who was an uncouth countryman
who believed that democracy meant the
people should elect of the the president
and the government and remember we had
established a system of a republic but
it was an elite oriented controlled
Republic and but it was with the
generation of people who had won the
American Revolution and those people the
American Revolution for those who have
not studied it's a very important thing
to really study because it was a
revolution the great historians will
tell you it was a revolution from the
bottom up it was by the reason we have
the Bill of Rights was because the great
story about this in the first Congress
the only way they could get ratification
of Constitution after came out of
Philadelphia was by the agreement to put
in a Bill of Rights and some of the
people who actually opposed this in John
Madison who James Madison he was
brilliantly writing the Bill of Rights
with the Congress in the first session
that was the deal and one of the Georgia
representatives got up on the floor of
the house and said this was crazy I mean
he said somebody's going to come along
if we're not careful you thinking write
all this down and they're going to say
that's all the rights
you have the remember they had just won
a revolution they knew what their rights
were and in Madison came back the next
morning and said you know I've listened
to what the distinguished gentleman said
and he was absolutely right we need to
catch all and so he introduced what we
would know as 9th and 10th amendments to
the Constitution ninth amendment being
the amendment that says that which is
apparently nobody's ever remembered
there's a whole complicated reason about
the numbering of the amendments
originally 13 of them three of them are
really weird amendments and they just
didn't go anywhere but so they were out
of order numerically but the 9th
amendment was was to give the people the
rights that they retain rights that were
not stated in this document and
essentially natural rights and and I'm a
great believer in like the mint in the
10th amendments were giving the states
powers that the federal government had
not been explicitly given and and we
have been fighting about all of this
ever since but in 1824 Andrew Jackson
the victor of the Battle of New Orleans
former governor and senator from
Tennessee and considered a yahoo by most
of the political elite in what was then
Washington and East Coast a brand for
president against the system that they
had in this caucus system against Adams
and several other Crawford several own
people and ended up finishing second
believing that he had in fact been
cheated out of the election in the next
elections of John Adams John Quincy
Adams is elected in four years later
Jackson again decided to run and and he
would do this in the sweep the country
although every single every including
experienced wife and everything else and
they killed people and when to stop him
because he meant that the country meant
the people had decided this was going to
be a democratic republic they were going
to have to say and who would represent
them and lead them and they were not
going to settle for their betters
telling them what to do and I mention
this because we are
out of the historical moment of great
change in the paradigm and I want to
tell just a little bit of the story of
what how it happened what where the
party is today and follow up on some of
the things but I really need to talk
about where we are today because we are
in a moment of a new political paradigm
we are about to see the old the old
rules of being thrown out the old system
and the country has risen in revolt the
populace of the country has risen revolt
against the political class that did in
the end the economic political class who
have been dominating this country for
several decades and and it is and on
this revolution is real now the
mainstream media and the people in
Washington they don't get it they can't
understand what's happened for those of
you who have been managed to watch Fox
I've been talking since night since 2014
the end of the election I said we are
going to have in 2016 the most chaotic
political year of our lifetime including
1968 and hopefully without the violence
but the American people were and I
called it at that time we had entered a
what I called a pre revolutionary moment
I'll tell you what it was I've been
doing this project which I now known as
the candidate Smith project was a deep
attitudinal polls not the kind of light
poles that are done with not very many
questions or whatever designed to
reflect the results of the people asking
but to really discover I had some
friends who were donors who gave me the
money and said we want you to explore
your hypothesis that something's going
on and I did and my god what we found
and in since then and I predicted what
I'm predicting in the 14 and also I said
which was important that the driving
force of this after the in December of
2014 after the independence you joined
the Republicans to give the Republicans
their second massive midterm of victory
when the speaker mr. Boehner and the
Senate Majority Leader now to be
McConnell when
to a back room and came out with the
Omnibus appropriations bill in which
they gave Barack Obama a hundred percent
of everything he wanted immigration was
fully paid for Obamacare what have you
and the Republican rank-and-file rioted
in the country and I said they are about
the the established of the Republican
parties in danger being overthrown now
they don't get this they still trying to
figure out what's happened and in the
Democratic side this was not a one-sided
thing the idea that a 74 year old
socialist running against the not only
presumed nominee of the Democratic Party
but the rigged person who was the entire
party was going to be sure was to be
coordinated put Hillary Clinton against
the wall
and if it had not been for the rigged
rules which I can mention a minute about
the Democratic Party he would have
toppled her and that is because the
country and a lot of young people joined
up the people who were supposed to be
too too egotistical and too much into
their own things actually joined up but
the interesting thing is I like to say
all from the beginning is it Sanders and
Trump were something out of the same
trough but from opposite ends that there
was in a country that's supposed to be
entirely divided we are divided except
by one thing we are divided we are
unified in massive numbers over the fact
that this country is no longer the
people believe that they rule in this
country I will tell you in its genius in
its genetic memory is a country where
these this is the people's government
and they have had enough of being led to
failure by a bunch of belize who
basically sit around and
and in dictate what it is the American
people must do because they tell them
and that includes the mainstream media
which I believe as is the is an extra
party here has basically destroyed or is
in process of undermining the First
Amendment the reason we have freedom of
the press was not because the founders
liked the press they hated the press but
the reason was that Jefferson said you
cannot have a pretty government without
a free press so they were the only
institution without checks and balances
they would be unencumbered by checks and
balances and a system built on checks
and balances because their job the
implicit bargain of the First Amendment
is they would protect the people from
power they would be the people's Tribune
instead what they have done in recent
years is they have not only deserted
their very implicit constitutional duty
and deserted the ramparts of protecting
the Americans from their government from
excesses of power they have actually
joined up and become the outriders of a
political class that is so corrupt that
the country ranks that really if you ask
them no one will mention it's like the
Harry Potter word the ballot whatever
that is Bela Dora I can never get my
grandchildren them anyway the the point
is the one were not allowed to be spoken
in Washington is a word corruption and
yet if you ask people on the scale of
questions to rank them the number one
issue or the number two it's usually
that or won or tied with the economy has
been government ethics and corruption in
Washington and ethics in corruption it's
been behind a couple places is special
interest but let me just say what the
big point I'll give you some quickly
nation numbers and I'm going to make
blend points but the I had a question
that I gave to Scott Rasmussen a few
years ago that I wanted to have him
asking that I picked it up and use it
myself which is as those of you in the
students who have studying those adults
remember your Declaration of
Independence which is these Lincoln said
the sheet brought that document of
American government that beyond the
Constitution it is the founding document
and it states with the purpose
of a people in revolution was and they
said in the third paragraph or fourth
paragraph Jefferson writes in this at
the time the government's who derived
their legitimate power from the consent
of the governed and when the kid to
govern and he goes on to say were not
lightly the light matter did to
overthrow it but the people had not only
the right but the duty to do so if the
government no longer represented them I
asked this question and we asked it
regularly and the question is we
explained in the Declaration of
Independence it says the legitimate role
of government is that it drives its
authority from the consent of the
government from the governed do you
think the government in Washington is
represents the people three quarters
somewhere between 70 and 75 percent of
the American people say it no longer
governs with the consent of the people
that is when I said in 2013 this is the
beginning of a pre revolutionary moment
and it has been followed by by a lot of
things and let me just give you a few
because and then I'm going to talk about
Democratic Party quickly and then we'll
get to hopefully the questions look we
are not you know you hear the polls
about 67 70 % of people say we're on the
wrong track much bigger than that
is a question that I've been asking flat
out which is that America is in a state
of decline 768 before the past I just
got new numbers as high as 71% in this
October of Americans an electorate says
that this country is in decline people
believe that they're the other two
they're two things that framed this
moment we're in in a big atmospheric way
another is the question the people who
believe that the were you better off
financially that you then your parents
were than adults that is now actually
turned negative before it's been very
positive people saying they did but
overwhelmingly people said that the next
generation their children would not be
better off the basic fundamental moral
commandment of this republic has been
before it was even a
it was people came here so that they
could give their children better than
neighbor see 21 22 generations of
Americans have lived that it is not a
bumper ship we are now in the process is
Miss Clinton would have a problem
understanding that we are denying our
children and the students in this room
and the lineal zin this country and my
grandchildren daughter and family we are
denying them their rightful heritage
that they would inherit a better America
with more opportunity than we got
instead we have devouring their future
and that is a moral issue and the third
big idea is this we ask people do you
believe the system the system is there's
a system now work where everyone more or
less plays by the same rules to get
ahead or the system is rigged but the
well connect to those with well
connected with money that is 84 percent
to 10 believing it is a system with the
rich and powerful just like there are
3/4 the American people who I wonder
where they got the notion believe
there's one set of justice for those in
power or the Clintons and then there's
another for you these are some of the
big questions but I just want to quickly
give you a couple of their that are
stunning in their this is what this was
the last time I did this about six
months ago and I've got new numbers in
there the highest ever political leaders
in America more interested in protecting
their power and privilege than what
doing what is right for the American
people that was 84 it's up to 89 the
power
this is Democrats Republicans across the
board independence this is where Occupy
Wall Street meets the tea party the
power of ordinary people to control our
country is getting weaker every day is
political leaders on both sides fight to
protect their own power and privilege at
the expense of the nation's well-being
we need to restore what we really
believe in real democracy by the people
and real free enterprise and that is now
that was 81 it's now in the
ladies powerful interests of Wall Street
banks the corporation unions and
political interest groups have used
campaign and lobbying money to rig the
system for themselves they are looting
the national treasury of billions of
dollars at the expense of every man
woman and child seventy-five percent of
people believe it then it's almost 90
today I believe the US government is
working in the people's best interest
well that didn't go over too well that's
over 70 good well here's my favorite
politicians really care about people
like me
eighteen percent agree and seventy four
six percent disagree and the eighteen
percent of what I would say that is the
political class the country is run by an
alliance of incumbent politicians media
pundits lobbyists and other powerful
moneyed interest groups for their own
gain at the expense of the American
people that is about debt is 80 percent
and now it's about 85 and the I in a
couple of other quick ones the u.s. than
biased and slanted media coverage of the
median press or a fundamental part part
of the problem of our political system
three-quarters of the American people
the American media according to Gallup
has its lowest ratings ever in the last
several months and I wonder why as
people have figured out that they are
biased that they are unfair and that
they have their own agenda and it's not
enough you know my problem of media is
this it is not enough merely they tell
us who we must vote for and who you may
not go for it is when they decide to
tell you what truth you're allowed to
know and what truth you are not allowed
to know and that is what they're doing
suppressing information and thank God
for the Internet and so many forms of
information that we have
the US has a two-track economy where
most Americans struggle everyday with
good jobs are hard to find where huge
corporations get all the rewards we need
fundamental changes to fix the
inequities in our economic system that's
three quarters or more the people a
major reason of the middle class has not
seen their economic condition really
improved for decades in the nation does
not have the economic growth it needs is
because corruption and crony capitalism
in Washington that put special interest
the head of the nation a majority of
Americans almost 80% of the people agree
with that and here is wanted I like
every week we seem to see more and more
news stories about government and
competence in overspending mismanagement
the federal government is not only
dysfunctional but seems to be collapsing
in front of our very eyes in almost
three-quarters of the American people
believe that and the reeling here is a
killer and this gets into the party it's
a real struggle in America is not
between Democrats and Republicans but
between the mainstream America in the
political ruling elites that is 67 to 24
believe that 3/4 to two-thirds of the
American people mainly in the country
we're told there are only Democrats and
Republicans and now remember we have a
country hmm where independents are for
the first time the plurality of our
country both parties are on the verge of
being really Oh crushed by this up this
election season has been built on a
structure done to protect the two powers
in the two parties and power whatever
differences they seem to have except as
I said when they get behind closed doors
and start cutting up the pie and and and
the things that go on and taking care of
themselves and their own interest it is
a facade we aren't this is a Potemkin
village of democracy the American people
do not believe they rule and they do not
believe that they are heard and they
meant to be heard this year in any
system established so it could and
that's how you end up with the Donald
Trump being nominated the most unlikely
of all possible people
wins and Hillary Clinton survives
because my party is rigged and I want to
spend a few minutes talking about what's
happened to my party which I describe as
a party of memory
professor Hamby today talked about the
legacy of the album of the progressive
populist movement in this country and
then with FDR Truman JFK Lyndon Johnson
Jimmy Carter all the way down about
American foreign policy the movement
against him begin and remember the
person who oppose government unions was
named Franklin Roosevelt he said you
should not have you can't have them
negotiating across the table we have the
civil service system and he refused to
do it and then John Kennedy just went
and signed in Monday and now that unions
unions not the labor union it's not two
people work in an industry that the
Democratic Party represents it is a
party of government employee unions
particularly teachers unions those
unions not the teachers their job is to
make sure we have no Educational
Progress in this country and what we
have seen my party become is a party of
interest groups when we said whether the
original purpose when Chris Ramsey said
today from the beginning of the
Democratic Party was the idea that we
would be the party of the people when
two hundred years ago when in 1792
Thomas Jefferson and Madison took a trip
by a botanical trip on the Hudson
looking for butterflies and met up with
DeWitt Clinton the book New York and
they form the modern Democratic Party
the oldest political party in the world
and what's interesting is you can be as
in see the decline of my party in 1992
at the convention when Ross Perot by the
way was having was at that moment on top
of the country was ready to dump the
parties then they were ready for an
outsider and but there's a long story
but that Perot pulled out and there's a
lot of strange quirks going on there
that we don't have time for those war
stories I met him on January 3rd 1992
flew to Dallas and began discussions
with him about making this right
but anyway but we have now where we have
basically or a one-party system and it's
got wings and I call we have the
corruption party in the stupid party
corrupted and they--but there's a lot of
beech in both but you can figure out who
is who pretty clearly but my party has
become a corrupt party and this is
amazing to me
it serves what does it serve first of
all it moved over 1990 to 1992
convention Ron Brown the chairman it was
a true under thany bursary Democratic
Party there was no mention of that at
the Democratic convention in 1992 and
the second thing they did then was Bob
Casey the governor of Pennsylvania who
is pro-life was denied the right to
speak at a Democratic convention of
which he was added one of the largest
states while they loud moderate
Republican women who approached
pro-abortion to speak and that was the
beginning of the stifling of dissent in
my party which was supposed to be the
party of free expression and it has now
become a party bent on suppressing all
facts or truths and it is now and that
is because it is essentially been
hijacked hijacked by a coalition a very
well educated very snob on what I call
the swells of the well-educated money
people whatever in the interest groups
when the 1992 the Democratic Party
became the party of Wall Street now the
Republicans were really upset and
couldn't wait to try to become the party
of Wall Street again but but you know
for a long time the major funding and
Democratic Party was Wall Street Hillary
Clinton is a walking embodiment she's
raised untold millions from the hedge
fund industry in Wall Street and
whatever and she gave a speech today
saying she was going to be really tough
on these banks and all I wanted Donald
Trump to do what is this anybody believe
that people give you a hundred million
dollars or fifty sixty and want nothing
in return they do it because they like
you that's why her speeches are not
public but it is a party that has lost
its soul and as soul was to represent
the common man it still survives on that
but it does and all you have to do is
look at the inner cities of America
and Donald Trump is to be applauded for
going to those places at least raising
the banner and about what has happened
in the inner city because the Democratic
Party's other interest group is
political ly interest group leaders and
particularly in the minority where they
buy off the politicians that's what
happens and nothing gets done for the
people nothing and we are supposed to be
the party that was supposed to take it
the Republicans have a problem and an
empathy problem like they can't talk
about blacks and Hispanics in their
cities sorry to say but Trump goes out
there and they may says the truth you're
getting killed look at your unemployment
look at the jobs look what you don't
have and it is because they can take
your vote for granted which is true and
because the schools look at the schools
why because the Democratic Party is in
the pocket of the teachers unions just
like you cannot change the DA because my
party has become the party of government
unions and there won't then they will
not allow anyone to be fired including
people of responsible for killing
thousands of veterans what kind of
country is this but that is not to say
sadly to say the Republicans offer a
whole lot more as I said you know they
promised they would stop Obama they laid
down died in streets when he did illegal
acts we have Iran going on we have the
greatest crisis in American foreign
policy overwhelmingly the American
people but pose the Iran nuclear deal
that got there on their own
two thirds many Democrats included in
the White House told the Democratic side
oh no you just felt with us don't worry
about it and nobody will remember
well they do remember and over almost 75
percent of American people say that Iran
is not only was is either cheating or
will cheat on the deal and that ever
since we did this deal all we've done is
render what we know we've done we put
billions of dollars in cash in pallets
we took off secretly sanctions that were
supposed to stop them and what do you
hear from the Republicans nothing they
do not fight and we have sailors
humiliated on their boats they built the
the Iranian Guard built statues
commemorating the American sailors who
are put on their knees with guns at
their heads and John Kerry had the
audacity to say well see the nuclear
deal we finally got them free because
now we can talk to them well by three to
one Americans think that that was a
national humiliation but not to me and
will they will not these things are not
being told what we have now is this
moment in our history when I think the
Republican Party has no I don't know
what it does because I don't know what
it stands for it certainly doesn't stand
for its voters and they're angry - how
dare them do this I mean the most rabid
anti Trump stop comes out of Washington
from places like the Wall Street Journal
the Washington Post conservatives quote
conservatives who feel offended that
their power to lose is being taken on
what might be taken away from them or
the two people because they're really
just as contemptuous and that's the
interesting thing when you ask about the
deplorable deplorable comments voters
think the plurality that this is Hillary
showing real contempt by the way that
18% of said polish
that's the same percentage of people who
say that that when asked about her
statement that she should have
apologized that's exactly right that
that's who these people are
that's the only in this country and they
have taken this country to the brink of
disaster and the American people know it
now and that is why this election is so
unclear we have an election and it is
very frustrating because I believe the
deity issues and the things that I'm
talking about if Donald Trump would stop
defending his the hell that anyone cares
about his life for and starts speaking
for what he promised to be the spokesman
of the American people the elite are not
trying to stop Donald Trump they're
trying to stop the American people from
threatening their power and it is a
moment when the country needs to new
breath of democracy I had once said long
ago that in the hands of these people in
the hand these people the the bait the
spirit the power of democracy is dead in
the hands of the American people it is
it is an amazing magic tonic nothing the
American people have never been able to
do when they have been calling the shots
and it is time I don't care whether and
I think everyone believes us and if we
had an election on that basis which is
this whose country is this who governs
America who's America does this belong
to are we going to continue going down
the road of decline or what I call the
globalist attitude of well we'll make
sure it's a soft landing while we make
sure our families and we are all
protected and have and have ripped off
everything to make sure we're okay and
what we'll make sure it's not too
upsetting and I'll tell you as I have
said before this country to paraphrase
Dylan Thomas one of my favorite poets
this this this is America this country
is not going to go gently in that good
night of decline faced with decline the
American people will do whatever is
necessary to restore what is the
exceptionalism in the
country and what we need to first do and
we need to do it for our children and
grandchildren we need to tell the young
people it's their country and they
deserve better than they're getting and
we're going to do something about it and
that's what the election should be about
and that is what my party is no longer
about as they as I said they have what
they have become and that's why they you
know as I said it's a party of memory to
me I refuse to stop believing in what I
believe which is a strong foreign policy
you know someone bill o'reilly they said
that he wrote all living presidents and
asked them whether or not could he just
did a book on on the killing of Japan or
the Rising Sun and he said would they
support it would they have done with
Truman did in dropping the unabomb and
the two bushes said yes and Jimmy Carter
said yes and Bill Clinton didn't answer
for obvious reasons he doesn't want to
get in any more trouble but Barack Obama
didn't answer and you we all know the
answer of that question because he
doesn't believe in American
exceptionalism and every president
Democrat a Republican Bill Clinton
everyone all believed in American
exceptionalism you cannot lead this
country if you do not understand why it
is so special and why it became a place
made up of people from every place in
the world who made it turned it into a
race of people different from anyone
from which they had come and that is the
promise of America and that is what is
being lost here so anyway that's my take
on this and we can do questions on the
campaign
hi thank you very much for speaking
today I was just wondering
could you elaborate maybe on the steps
that you think would be necessary to fix
the directions in America is going well
the first thing to do is is that that
you the political class in my opinion
has to be displaced there this has to be
turned upside down
now I don't know what kind of president
Trump would be my reasons everyone has
to make their own choices on this but my
belief is that we've got big issues on
the table if they're able to win if they
were able to suppress the American
people they will be charged with more
power than they've ever had and they
will seek to snuff out which is what
they're doing choke off the legitimate
dissent of the American people to their
failures they have brought this country
to this point and they and they say oh
we're so good do you don't think it's a
coincidence do you that in Washington
this is in a battle between Democrats
and Republicans or liberals and
conservatives it is a battle between the
American people and the political class
and their outriders and the first thing
is they must be defeated and if Donald
Trump would just raise that point and
then now that he is they are not trying
to stop Trump although you know there's
a lot of people think he should be they
are trying to stop you they're trying to
stop the American people that's the real
threat or the American people and that
is what this election needs to be
decided on the minute they lose the
world turns upside down and then I think
Trump should do what he promised to do
on an apprentice and start and fire
these people you know let the American
people not him American people start
firing people should be you know what
you fail in any way of teaching a
country that is okay to fail we tell our
young people don't worry you don't have
to win that is real life is about
winning and losing but it's also about
compassion and it's about caring for one
another but for God's sakes you cannot
have a protected class or peggy noonan
calls them the protected class running a
riot on the
unprotected class that 18% versus the
rest of the country and this is the
first step because then we need new
generation of new leaders not people
who've been in Washington they look at
this you have all of these Bush people
these two legacies of these of these of
the hereditary elite the bush people and
the Clinton people and notice how the
curtain goes up we try and all of a
sudden they're all out there on her side
I mean they're all screwed oh no we
can't do this we can't have known oh my
god to be nuts because they have all
been in bed together making this country
what it is and working for each other
when you have groups that these
consultants easy to discover when you
have all these people in Washington
enriching themselves lobbying the
Consulting Group's
and they have people like you know you
know you have scooter libby was in
business with the guy who was got rich
Mark Rich's Pardons Jack Quinn who was I
used to doing as an idealist problem
with powers power corrupts and people
who stayed become corrupt and these
people are in business together
there this is that's the fraud you can
see it right in front of you but they
pretend that they really have battles
going on and it's usually about issues
then I'm not saying they're not
important but they are not about whether
the country lives or not so the first
thing is we need real Americans to come
and do what we had when we had citizen
politics people came to government to
serve and go home and the first thing to
do is to make these people leave Woodrow
Wilson to his credit when he was
inaugurated in his inauguration he's
totally lobbyists in Washington which
were them are not powerful but they were
nothing telling the pack up and leave
town and they did because they would
have no power in his city McCain we need
to understand these are the people
running the country and they're the
people and all of these 70% of the
people who leave Congress they don't go
home
they go to work for lobbying companies
and lobbyists in Washington let me just
ask
you a simple common-sense question do
you really think when they're sitting
there voting and thinking about their
future that they're going to hurt the
people that they plan to have hire them
huh who do you think they're going to
take care of you of them and that's why
that's got to stop
Barack Obama cleaned he was going to
stop all this but like most of what he
says it's a mirage I mean the man lives
in his own bubble you know and and I say
that as someone anyone who knows Chicago
politics knows and I have been very
steeped in Chicago politics so I know a
lot about it but he is a man that that
is a I'm sorry
a really they say Trump is ego driven in
he is but Obama is an ego obsessed lives
in his own dream world as he decides to
make America like the rest of the world
anyway next question I can't see so
stand up or talk or say something like
I'm sorry too bright um I could listen
to you for hours all as long as I can
I'll stay here till I collapse over will
my feeling I've told people a trump is
was never my first pick but I feel like
that if he were elected it would be the
destruction of the Republican Party and
maybe somebody would start fixing the
problem that you're talking about and it
sounds like do you think that if Hillary
were elected anything would change in
the Democratic Party let me tell you the
one of my greatest concern is this is
what I said about the enemies listed
last night I have to tell you was the
most appalling thing as a Democrat is
about descent during the Vietnam War
Lyndon Johnson was president they were
very powerful president and there were
people in my party who thought the
policy was wrong who stood up and
opposed him a great potential cost to
themselves the Robert Kennedy's and the
Bill Fulbright's and others there's some
people who Johnson had control
three years they because at that point
it was a matter of conscience during
Watergate as I said I was youngest
person on Nixon's enemies left so I have
this thing about government corruption
and uses of government I'm in and they
were Republicans who stood up on
conscience in principle the little ykers
the bill Cohen's
and others in there in the Republican
Party because the Constitution the
country because Nixon had violated those
terribly today we have rampant
corruption we have the most we have a
corrupt machine that's so vast the
Clinton machine and no not a single
Democrat will stand up on principle and
say this we can't do this they are all
in that this is the death of my party in
the sense of any moral Center if it
lives because it Stokes the fires of
identity politics and whatever it does
and divide people whatever but she is
let me just say this no one has said and
what needs to be said Laura Ingraham
hinted this and I tested 70% of people
agree with this 60-some percent of me
say if you elect Hillary Clinton and she
appoints all the judges and all the
prosecutors and all the heads of agency
there will be nobody to stop her and you
know what the American people know that
if Donald Trump would only say that's a
real issue that Clinton Foundation is a
single most corrupt Enterprise in
American history it is we're going to
turn this country if you move that what
they did in the State Department into
the White House you are talking about
turning America into a banana republic
and the South American model corruption
is look America can survive incompetence
it can survive periods of stupidity we
have often but what it cannot survive is
the poison of the cancer of corruption
eating away at every element of this
where every there are no truths
everything is a lie lying is now the
currency of the political class
nobody cares about truth and nobody
cares about saying the
people you know why the American people
are right to have contempt for the for
what's going on washing because the bill
greider of quite leftist a good friend
of mine and a great man
wrote long time ago in a book called who
will tell the people and he said before
the American people became content
contempt for their government and their
leaders their leaders first had contempt
for them and that's what I mean when I
say that the country overwhelming
majority believed that Hillary Clinton's
comments represent the views of the
Joplin 60-some percent say that is the
view of the political class in the media
and they've got it right now what needs
to be done is told they don't know
nothing they don't you know this country
they don't we've separated in something
very bad Washington is so rich and
corrupt and that's why the suburbs are
booming and everyone else is suffering
and they don't see it they don't live
where we live they don't live with the
people live they do not could send their
children to schools or you send your
children to they don't have to
experience anything they have protected
themselves and they think they have a
right they they think that they are some
kind of ruling class this is America and
they need to be overthrown in the way we
were taught we have a constitutional way
to do it and that is what we should use
and if it requires a blunt instrument to
do it then we need the blunt instrument
because right now it's a question of
stopping what I believe is a single
greatest threat in my lifetime to the
future of this country and that is the
corruption Hillary Clinton lives and
believes in in his part up she her
husband their donors all of those people
they took all third of America's uranium
supply and gave it to the damn Russians
for money but you don't read this in the
press they're the new line in the press
oh well she's a crook but so was Trump
he is nowhere near which he has done and
what they have done to this country
selling favours yes down here we have
some people I think oh go ahead man
me that's been left out of discussion is
the role of the voter you're quoting 60
65 70 75 80 85 percent we have nowhere
near those numbers of people voting and
until the people speak their outrage
through their vote how is it going to
change well that's why we have to have
an election where someone will speak for
them and that is my frustration with
Donald Trump his job is not to be about
himself but to be about us and to tell
people that this the overwhelming
majority people believe this is the one
chance the American people have to take
their country back this election without
any names to take their country back
from the special interest in the
political class and that's close to 70%
and all he's got to do is get up there
and say did this thing on the town mean
long because hey if you people believe
what I'm going to tell you this if
that's what you think there's only one
thing for you do it's time for them to
go and it's time for us to take a chance
and better we do that I am so - it's
looks like what happened in England
would brexit when the elites kept saying
the world will come to an end and not
only that will cause it to come to an
end if you dare not do what we tell you
and you know what the British economy
guess what it's doing well how about
that and you see these national uprising
where people in other countries in
Europe are saying you mean we're going
to take they were letting these refugees
that's how Isis ins infiltrated and in
Germany when they've had not pleasant
experiences and all of scandal have no
idea to embrace the violence again all
of that and they've said enough Angela
Merkel is on her way out and she's the
most powerful woman in the world and the
most powerful political leader people in
the world have had enough of this it is
not about we can have a global society
but we cannot have a society run by a
bunch of globalist who are all in bed
together taking care of one another
who think that their job their that
they're very that their allegiance is to
that creed rather than the
responsibility to their own countries
mr. Cadell over here what look right
here
ah there you are sir okay gotcha okay um
I want to hit on something you said
earlier you said that this is a pre vote
pre revolutional I said that three years
ago we are in the middle of the
revolution yeah this is the revolution
um do you believe that this revolution
will be one that will break out in
violence and if so how can we prevent
this chaos and violence and still purify
our government or is it even possible to
do one without the other
well no no we don't have to have
violence I believe I've deeply against I
believe what Jefferson said when he said
you know we have the means to do this if
we just believe in ourselves we have a
system when they will not we can talk to
each other we have the Internet's we
have other name the country can come to
a consensus it needs leadership badly
but what I have been warning for some
years about if the Eden if the
continuing ignoring of the rightful
dissent and alienation the American
people would result in and if this
election fails and she gets in and
becomes running the next time may not be
very pretty but we will the thing I've
always worried about and I worry about
today and I say this to these elitist
idiots if you think you'd better worry
about you think Donald Trump's about you
have no idea
wait till you get someone what I call
and I've been talking about this someone
who is the political brilliance of Huey
Long who was the demagogue and I mean he
was really scared little sassy Roosevelt
was terrified and that person is a first
of all the Harvard Yale graduate he will
be a traitor to his class he will know
how to handle the media from day one
because he said this little earlier and
his message will be and he will he will
promise to fix things because we have a
problem in the economy which were
probably headed to in the world or
whatever and none of this is fixed and
all of it is still what I worry about is
eventually you will get someone and they
may or may not be very good but I'll
tell you the number that we had the
highest in this new poll and I got it
actually from the Quinn tivey Act people
from the spring
it was about we need a powerful leader
who will save us from our problems that
is the definition of the man on
horseback today that is 90 percent of
people saying that beyond this election
so if we don't want violence but as I
said the American people are not going
to accept this is Britain we are not
going down to be a third world country
or to reduce country or to lose our
exceptionalism without a fight that is
not going to happen and I'm saying we
don't have to happen but we have to
first of all is state to principles and
have this this needs to be the
organizing principle it needs to be the
one for young people because they
inherit this country and those are the
students here who have been really
screwed I mean this is ridiculous when I
was in contact of all I had to worry
about when I was a college is getting
drafted but there was no question when I
got out to there be a job and I'd have
opportunities my parents had struggled
because they kept the faith we have not
kept the faith and it is time to start
keeping the faith but it starts with our
job as citizens this is our country
answer is it let the if the American
people want to dismiss this country up
it's their right it's their country and
just too and that they want to end what
is the greatest Lincoln said the last
best hope of Earth then so be it on our
heads but let us at least try to live up
to what we remember and what if they
would teach us something and that's why
what you teach is important colleges and
why we need to get out of this
curriculum stopping these colleges of oh
my god I mean to the witch I can frankly
tell you could end it tomorrow what's
happening is public university under
title 9 you just end it all but on free
speech whatever is first of all we need
to understand who we are and where we
come from because when you know that
you'll know it's in your blood and I
don't care who you where you came from
whether you came from South America or
Africa or whatever people come here to
be free and to prosper and that this is
we are if you don't do that as a nation
we will you think the Balkans is a
problem look at all of us
our religions don't Unitas our ethnicity
doesn't Unitas our class does the United
are different clad those things
terrorists buy with the unites us is an
idea and it is the most powerful idea in
the history of man that people should be
no longer pawns pushed around by by the
Royals but that they should be
self-determined it and that people are
given god-given rights and that these
are you know life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness and that we stand
for these they mean something
hello um I've heard some accused Trump
of being nothing but a self-promoting
opportunist you on the other hand seem
to see him as maybe the champion of
those not in the political class do you
think it's possible for him to be both
well it's you know this country has had
its major things Shawn I have an
advantage I've known Trump for many
years and I've there many things I can
criticize but his concern about the
country is very genuine he started
talking about these things 10 years ago
when he says he was against the Iraq war
I said this Hannity after the last
debate not only him I was in the room
with it I listen to this he was he was
thought it was a dumb exercise and
Nicole we get nothing for it was
ridiculous and I mean I don't agree with
him anyway but his motivations on that
but he is an egomaniac and he is you
know anybody but look it had to be
somebody from the outside nobody in this
system was going to challenge it so
therefore you get the vehicle item as
long as he understands what he seems to
be trying to grasp does he tried to do
with the convention that I am your voice
I am your vehicle and if he would get up
and say that and my claws are many but I
stand for the people's right to rule
this election would be over in a
landslide
so he'd the perfect choice was not my
choice I wanted to get somebody tried to
find some because I thought it was time
for what I didn't have time tonight to
talk about candidate Smith a candidate
who could unite a 70 to 60% majority of
the American people but this system
wouldn't allow that and he had to have
somebody could self fund themselves and
also understood they could get a lot of
publicity nobody else would have gotten
the attention and none of the other
candidates were going to say any of this
what do they all want to do let me just
go back to the Republican Party for a
sec primarily he had Marco Rubio on
paper look really good what did he want
to do he was going to be for the three
stools of his of his presidencies you
said one of them was TPP and the other
one was crawling up is
are up to a certain orifice of the
Republican establishment as he could go
and Boyd no one cared to hear about that
Ted Cruz
I've told Ted Cruz two years this is not
about ideology about insurgency but he
had to run as an ideologue and whatever
in it people didn't want it they sent a
mess when evangelicals were voting in
the south for Donald Trump they said but
something is more important in social
issues to us it's about the country and
the press and the Republicans can't
figure that out
look who MSNBC and CNN filled their show
with first of all they fill them with
the fail consultants like Mike Murphy
who ripped off Jeb Bush and Meg Whitman
before that he's now and lost spent a
hundred and thirty million dollars and
got Jeb Bush three delegates and he is
the most anti Trump person he's been
hired as an analyst of NBC News you
would think failing I mean that's called
failing upward in a way that's beyond me
they also have Rick Tyler he got fired
out of the Cruz campaign and now he's
there to attack you have Nicole Wallace
a bushy from in from the Georgia than
the second Bush 43 and she might as well
be she is there they got so many people
on CNN SC in and that's their view will
have for liberals and we'll have to hate
de trop hating Republicans and that's
fair and balanced even at Fox look how
hard it's been I mean you got voices
there this is not easy to make a message
but Trump had those things and he needs
to use them now for the country Mexico
know let's all take some more quell I'll
last a little longer if they did people
people can leave if they want you don't
have no-one's obligate this day this
year the Democrats came really close to
nominating a socialist if in the future
they bring up they managed to
successfully bring up a socialist
nominee like Bernie Sanders would that
help the Democrats or with were would it
leaves more disasters like 1970 200
remember what he was saying except his
only problem was with Sanders I've known
Sanders for many years even saying this
stuff for 30 40 no one paid attention he
didn't create this moment those voters
created this moment they found him and
at least he was authentic is not unlike
her I mean anyone who thinks she's
authentic is really must be taking
certain kinds of pills or smoking things
I mean this woman would say anything to
anybody I mean she's so desperate and
she's repeated all of the positions of
her husband and then says oh we had a
great administrator but I'm against all
of our things and when she was four
super predators that was one thing and
when she was taking out women and I
don't think Trump should make those
issues but she's you know she is a
desperate woman and and and sees her
role is if I can only get my hands on
power and the people with her that's all
they care about a lot of people as I say
with orange hair trying to get their
hands on housing contracts and other
things but now Bernie Sanders
represented a certain authenticity and
what he said welp the corruption was
real he just refused to say it about her
and what he should have done and I had
no more reliable for my no respect point
I mean because I knew the Democratic
Party was never going to nominate a
socialist are you kidding this party is
owned by special interests and
corporations they own they rent the
Democratic Party and they tend to own
the Republicans in Washington and they
really in and the fact is they were
never going to allow that to happen and
they made the rules to make sure they
didn't the long story of how those
things have been rigged but no I don't
think that's going to happen it wasn't
this policies like that it was the fact
that he was the protest he was the anti
and at least he
seemed to be a man of some conviction in
the land of the blind the one-eyed man
is king you know and in the Democratic
Party I mean even a socialist but he
wasn't going to go elected with that but
the point was it was over that's where
the were he was a vehicle for the revolt
there was no one else just as there was
no one else other than Trump and that is
a sad system because they did run and
nobody else could or would or could put
it together thank you for being here
tonight it's the first time voter I feel
like the Republican Party has fallen
into reactionary politics rather than
principled politics I fully planned on
voting Republican until Trump was
nominee as such I plan on voting for the
Libertarian Party this year many young
voters feel the same way I do we see
this is not something that's based on
principle but rather based upon
demography based upon reaction and we
feel that both parties no longer speak
for us how does the Republican Party
change to become more appealing to young
voters such as myself well the only way
the Republican Party is going to change
when the grassroots cleans out its
establishment of the lobbyists
consultant class in Washington that are
the most not only corrupt but they are
the most incompetent people they lost an
election in 2012 I didn't think could be
lost they lose all kinds of things I
don't think can be lost
it just has to show you actually people
tend to favor the Republican principles
generally more because they win anyway
at the local level I mean these people
are beyond belief and you know the and
the answer and I have to say look this
election where everyone has to vote
their conscience Liberty I mean I
understand what you're saying in people
it's hard to vote for you know the
lesser of two evils is often evil that's
what I learned when I was your age in
1968 when I was debating whether I could
vote for Hubert Humphrey or not against
Richard Nixon and and they'll never
forget my radical classmate who said
wouldn't do it and I was saying well I'm
going to do and he said no he said the
lesser of two
is evil and you know what I've thought
about that all my life and it's been
kind of true but this is a special
election and the question is the stakes
and do you have to base it on your
conscience if that's how you peel you
should make the protest vote what I and
I would hope that the young liberal
Millennials would do the same they're
voting for Gary Johnson and Jill stylish
if they feel that way they should they
don't have to take this they should
protest because they don't have to have
this this isn't their choice and it's in
but so you know do what you think is
right and to make that decision everyone
has to make I've come to a first time I
said a publicly I've come to a big
decision because they you hear what I
think the stakes are the other people
disagree with me they you know people
who work with me you know they think
Trump is a crazy man and then the women
who think he's awful but and he can be
the but that's because that's why this
election is in flux 1/4 of the American
people don't like either candidate and
they are the people as I said the saying
about Democrats and Republicans it's
really not what liberals serve besides
because I get in the numbers it's all
very confused it's those people who have
to and nobody has put the definition on
the table we supposed to have a
referendum on Donald Trump so that
Hillary can be President or should we
Donald Trump get it off his buck and put
out a bigger argument and let this be an
election about who owns the country and
then we'll have a different result
because a lot of those people who don't
like either people believe very strongly
in the numbers I'm saying and that is a
message that would help them decide this
is a right now as a race to the bottom
between these two campaigns and so
knowing to watch it do you believe that
implementing term limits for Senators
and Representatives could help prevent
the corruption from the elite class I'm
sorry Mia I'm sorry do you think that
having term limits for Senators and
Representatives yeah well I think it's
time for a lot of them to go you know
the problem of term limits is that
people get into they don't want to abide
by what they agreed some of them do like
Tom Coburn
fortunately because I have great
admiration for him the doctor who became
a senator and fought wasting government
and you know it was just a great man and
now he'll but you know you know what the
it's time to turn limit these people the
advantage they have with money with the
look we don't have a democracy when the
politicians pick the voters rather than
the voters picking the politicians and
that's what we have with all the
gerrymandering going on and it goes on
to write down to the we have machine we
have technology we never had before that
allows you go down to the block level
and decide which district to put you in
or not and well that's wrong and they
have unlimited fundraising and they got
all the interest groups and you know and
I think that you know it's I think that
would be very healthy development now it
would deprive us of some people who are
great public servants but frankly
they're not that many I can think of
very much thank you thank you